why do some young people from really
tough backgrounds beat the odds and what
can we all learn from them
[Music]
when I was a child I was bounced from
children's home to Children's Home yeah
it was tough but I made it as a writer
and as a poet
so this subject above all is very close
to my heart
how do you do it said night
how do you wake and shine
I keep it simple said like
one day at a time
there are no simple answers but we do
have some really interesting clues some
come from a major study which has been
following 12
000 children in four different countries
over a period of 20 years the young
lives team led by the University of
Oxford tracks children in Ethiopia Rue
Vietnam and India they looked at those
who'd managed to beat the odds and
pulled out a few common threads
here are three key ones
I didn't have family around me and the
absence of it actually gives you an
opportunity to see just how important
these supportive relationships are for a
child
I saw them because I didn't have them
think of a baby just learning to crawl
they only go so far before they look
back
when I looked back there was nobody
there
however tenuous having somebody who's on
your side
it's really important
for me I didn't realize it at the time
but the truth is my social worker was
that person he didn't feel like a role
model he didn't feel like a friend but
he was something more
he was a person keeping his binoculars
focused on my emotional state and that
that proved pivotal to me
second key element is the importance of
a safety net studies in the UK of
consistently shown a link between
poverty and poor outcomes for kids
children who experience persistent
poverty are four times more likely to be
in the bottom 10 in vocabulary aged five
small things can make a big difference
like the warmth of the relationship
between a parent and a child reading to
kids
and
having a safety net in those early years
is so important
in Ethiopia and Peru the young lives
team found children whose parents had
received government support for Basics
like food when they were very young had
significantly better long-term memory
and cognitive skills at the age of 12
than those who hadn't the more
disadvantaged the family the greater the
impact and their similar evidence from
the US were the baby's first Year's
study looked at the impact of giving
money to the poorest families in four
cities they gave twenty dollars a month
to one set of families the control group
and 333 dollars a month to the other
group
they then scammed the brains of the
babies at the age of one
and just look at the difference
the images on the left show the babies
from The High cash group and those on
the right from the low cash group the
babies whose mothers received the high
cash gift showed significantly more
activity in parts of the brain
associated with language and cognitive
skills
wow
[Music]
when I look back at my younger self all
I wanted was compassion and second
chances are about just that compassion
I was given a book of poetry by a
teacher in the children's home when I
was 13 years of age but it wasn't just
the book of poetry which helped me
though it did immensely it was also the
fact that I was worth giving a book to
I was lucky
because I found the thing I love
poetry and regardless of your upbringing
that's one of the greatest things that a
child or a person can ever find
what it is that they love
I'm not defined by Darkness confined in
the night
each Dawn I am reminded
I am defined by lights
[Music]
thanks for watching if you enjoyed that
be sure to check out these videos next
and if you haven't already hit the
Subscribe button and click the Bell to
get a notification each time we upload a
new video